i just want to address a lot of things
too you know especially the media came
out and said like
whoever said i was an angry guy i mean
for number one
uh you would would you be angry you know
if you're losing a week in a week out by
six and three points
uh and that is one of my biggest
problems you know i i do get upset when
we lose and
it takes me a while to get over it you
know i mean i i expect just like anybody
else you put the work in
and you want a w but sometimes a lot of
times last year it didn't go out it
didn't go like that
you know i mean so i i guess
they kind of miss screwed that and i
thought i was just around just angry
and and no gamer i was i was upset from
the losing was done but that's just the
winning enemy you know i mean like
as an inner guy i feel like who's who
plays this this professional level of
sports
that's leonard fournette talking to the
media yesterday wearing the batman suit
that is in no way embellished it's not
my god i i don't know what that was the
way that it fit him but i i was i was
scared i mean really it looks like he's
wearing a batman suit
without any type of you know
embellishment of the physique he could
be he could be batman no he is batman oh
i think we just need to start calling
barnett and batman face off i'm taking
fournette i mean he's the beast he is
like you know cut out and chiseled out
of granite i mean it is unbelievable the
specimen he is you know and to me that's
a great inside look of the frustrations
of football at times you could be one of
the most gifted football players in the
sport you have a crap team around you or
not the support system nobody will ever
know they won't and you know that's
where i think leonard
fournette's frustrations have come you
know his whole life he's been this
physical freak just dominating little
league football anything else like that
you know college football dominated that
when he wasn't hurt but he's gotten to
college and i mean the nfl and it's been
a struggle they haven't had a
quarterback a pass game the offensive
line has been a work in progress he's
had a deal with injuries so i understand
his frustrations but i still think he's
a hell of a player
another guy who entered with that big
splash at lsu and he's been chasing to
catch that level of performance since
then so what's more likely for 2020 the
more likely career arc for leonard
fournette devante freeman fizzling out
after three or four years sorry devonte
or mark ingram an effective role player
for a decade or longer i i think it's
the mark ingram uh is what i'm taking
here to be more likely first off leonard
fournette's just such a much bigger
human than devonta freeman you know
devonte freeman would be one of those
guys who you know he was like a mighty
mouse he he had a big punch but he
wasn't a real big guy and i think it
eventually caught up to him and that's
why he's you know not on a team right
now fournette you know is like like we
said physical freaky he's still got
tremendous speed and physical ability
and i just don't see him as being that
kind of guy that just fizzles out you
know out of nowhere here anytime soon
contract year for him too i mean it may
just be that he needs another
another team another environment another
opportunity to reset his career and get
the most out of that batman uh physique
all right more likely to happen in new
england this year with lamar miller
agreeing to term with the patriots
pending passing a physical which may not
be a gimme since he has a torn acl from
last august more likely he plays a
significant role in the patriots
backfield after missing all of last
season or that he disappears into the
new england abyss ala reggie wayne i i'm
gonna say he has a significant role uh
lamar miller you know yes didn't play
last year but two years ago was very
impressive i mean he is a guy that's
he's a home run hitter he can you know
bounce it outside and take it 70 yards
up the sideline he's always been that
type of player unfortunately you know
like the guy we just talked about he's
been on some teams the dolphins the
houston texans who have had just crap
offensive lines in front of them so
stats are never going to tell you how
good he is but the fact that he knows
that system being from billy o'brien and
then going into new england he'll have
the jump start there and you know them
they're never going to have a true bell
cow but i think he will be a part of
that rotation and have a serious role
this year he has a pair of 97-yard runs
in his stuff
which puts him it puts him in two spots
of a four-way tie for the fourth longest
run in league history he's there twice i
just tell his 87-yard runs a couple
years it tells you what kind of freaky
years miami and houston right well and
if he's healthy who knows what he can do
for new england it's going to be another
one of the situations where we say bill
belichick the genius at it again a guy
who's just out there waiting to be
signed and belichick does it all right
darius slay a guy who had played for a
belichick lieutenant matt patricia in
detroit traded to philadelphia had some
opinions about matt patricia uh here is
some of what slay had to say
what i love about this team man is that
um you can see that everybody is their
self you know they're not
in no shell
they can't um do this can't do that you
know uh it's basically kind of feeling
like you're being treated as grown men
and um i like the aspect of that man uh
i was
it's just the grown man treatment and
the ability to be yourself and not and
not be something that you're not and um
and they let you do that here and that's
why i think we're gonna have a lot of
fun and i think i'm it gonna be just the
gang up to come back fun again
look here's the bottom line here's what
i think happened in detroit i think that
when matt patricia got there he tried to
do the bill belichick giving hard
coaching to tom brady to darius slay
right out of the gate yeah and it just
didn't work yeah and and and again these
guys who work with bill belichick say
i'm not going to be like him but when
you've been with him for 15 years it
creeps in by osmosis you don't realize
that you're being like him and it just
blew up that relationship and that's why
it fell apart so now with sleigh who
arrived for only a third-round pick and
a fifth-round pick part of the eagles
defense more likely that philly is a top
ten defense with slay or the lions
improve to a top 15 defense without slay
oh i can't say the lions are gonna be a
top 15 defense i can't you know throw my
name on that i got to see some proof in
that pudding so i'm certainly not going
with that door this you know the lions
were what the 31st defense in football
last year you know so i got question
marks still about what they've done and
they've certainly improved their their
defensive roster but the eagles are a
team where i go you know i mean they're
part of those handful teams i think we
agree to go man if they could stay
healthy watch out for them this year you
know the defense yes with darius slay
malik jackson we forget he was hurt last
year you know derek barnett got hurt
last year they had a number of issues
that plagued them throughout the year
and yeah i think they're going to be a
much more of a force on the defensive
side of the ball this year than we saw
you know the previous two years fletcher
cox was banged up a lot of the year last
year so they never were really at their
best
let me just say this though for the
lions yeah the possibility of the old
edition by subtraction yeah i had a guy
for the last year who didn't want to be
there who was undermining the coaching
staff for every opportunity because he
he
felt disrespected from the get-go and
the new coaching staff didn't handle it
well sometimes sometimes moving that
that presence off of your roster
even if it takes away a very competent
player makes your team better agreed 100
about that you know i'm just not willing
to say i think the lions defense will be
better and that they've set up more of a
culture that fits the way matt patricia
and bob quinn you know deemed necessary
to win football games that's why we saw
an influx of new england guys sign there
this year they were probably like damn
you know we're sick of some of these
guys who can't take tough coaching who
were kind of pampered with other coaches
before us and you know had the red
carpet treatment that crap doesn't go
down in new england it's not for
everybody so they got more of their guys
in there to instill that culture we'll
see where it goes i do think there'll be
a better defense i just can't throw him
in the top 15 until i see a little play
first
all right quick break when we return
jason witten has jokes about something
that chris sims used to think was not
very funny at all more pft live right
after this i'm intrigued
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports